there's a guy by the name there are two
guys by the name of Joseph Langston and
another guy by the name of Richard scrub
scrubs
it's a tough name Essen or muster
Scruggs yeah okay so we got we got
Richard Scruggs and we got we got
Scruggs and we got Langston Langston
happens to know Wiley Wiley was his
pilot
well Langston and and Scruggs end up
getting indicted for bribing judges in
fact the out of Mississippi they end up
bribing a send-up driving a bunch of
judges Scruggs is the one of the law has
one of the largest tobacco settlements
in US history
for he got he convinced 46 and 46
different states he convinced multiple
tobacco companies to pay out two hundred
and forty six billion dollars he made
over a billion dollars himself he's one
of the richest [ __ ] attorneys ever
holy [ __ ] here's the interesting part is
he did that part of the way he did that
was bribing judges yeah judges juries
lawyers everything so when these guys
get indicted they got a major [ __ ]
problem problem is they got dirt on
everybody right so when the government
steps in and they've indicted these guys
do you prosecute these how hard you
prosecute these guys when these guys are
going to touch judges prosecutors other
lawyers defense attorneys they're gonna
and one of them is a u.s. senator what
one of the guys that was involved was a
US Senators thing about a senator can
put pressure on the on these tobacco
companies just seller sells or so so
they come in Langston gets indicted
Scruggs gets indicted they need to get
they come in they are gonna plead guilty
they plead guilty but they're gonna get
their sentence reduced how can you get
your sentence reduced you have to
cooperate yeah yeah that's fine
well yeah but if Danny and I both plead
guilty who am i cooperating against I
don't really have anybody so the more
you can provide assuming you have stuff
to provide which they don't have a lot
to provide so they're trying to get a
sweetheart deal well Wiley ends up
telling Langston listen I can give you
information and give you information on
on a company that's a that's uh is about
to be indicted they're going under they
stole a bunch of money it's a Ponzi
scheme I can give you information you
can give it to the government you'll get
a reduction for that and so Langston
says okay and I have the the report
that's the report where I said I had
that report where this was when he talks
to the FBI
Oh Joey Langston Langston gives the
information the the the source of the
information was Kevin Wiley and Langston
gives the information to the IRS well
what happens is the IRS ends up saying
and it's all on Capitol blue they talk
about Capitol blue at his sentencing
they talk about how he gave information
about Capitol blue and they're going to
reduce his sentence because of this
information he gave on Capitol blue okay
Danny for you to get a reduction you
give information to someone so I tell on
you you get sent in you get you found
guilty sentence and then I get my
sentence cut in two thousand and seven
or eight he was given a reduction on his
sentence he got thirty he got three
years he got three years Capitol blue
wasn't prosecuted until 2015
so you gave the information you got your
sentence cut before prop before Capitol
blue was even went to trial he'd already
served his time I was out years Wow
years before now the other guy I'm
pretty sure that a Scruggs is still is
still locked up he didn't have the
information and the problem is is that
if you look at it the IRS the agents say
that the information he gave didn't help
at all it was useless but they used it
to give him a reduction so how do you
cover up all this how do you make sure
that that he did give us information and
we did use it it did help
have to have the prosecution but but
Hamburg won't prosecute so DC comes in
takes the case and they prosecute
because we want to make sure there's
prosecution's and their people found
guilty because we give this guy a
sweetheart deal right so that's to me
that makes sense it's it's a loose
connection but it's it's a connection
for sure they're all and it's all
capital blue and it doesn't make sense
you gave this guy a reduction for
something there it just doesn't happen
doesn't happen so anyway so that's
that's all in the whole thing is and
here's the thing is that anything that
Donovan files Mendoza
automatically denies and you were asking
like why would he do that why does
Mendoza keep doing it so the only thing
that makes sense to me is one it was his
first case - you're you're bringing up
mistakes that he made
mm-hmm so my first case that lasted
eight or nine days costs probably a
million dollars to try and I kind of
botched the case I let in evidence and I
got a guy that says he's guilty and he
goes he went to prison it's better for
me to keep him in prison then for me to
say I [ __ ] up let's give him another
trial let's fix this damn I don't want
to say that people don't own up to their
[ __ ] yeah they better off bury it and
what does it matter we got some black
guy who digs digs holes
he said he sells dirt yeah so is he is
important as a federal judge's
reputation no of course not let him do
the time and honestly I'm sure in a
similar thing yeah kind of they they
don't want to they don't want to tarnish
their reputation yeah they're not gonna
take the fall for [ __ ] these guys
yeah same thing with rusev I'm he's a
drug dealer let him sit in prison it's a
man this guy and in spite I'm sure he's
justified it - yeah keep my oh yeah
Donovan he did get people to invest in
them into a theorem right yeah and and
look maybe even Mendoza initiative alien
deserves 17 right but when he gave it to
him he probably thought he did
yeah since then you've got you've got
you could at this point Mendoza knows
there's overwhelming blowback why right
why is the government destroyed evidence
yeah why have they destroyed why did
they erase the the servers hard drives
laptops exactly what and what about
these witnesses why these guys what the
affidavits at this point he's making
[ __ ] up to deny it
oh they're all on the same thought crazy
it was Frank on a day so the other thing
is and we had mentioned this was uh what
was funny is that uh so so I get out
right I get out of prison all this
stuff's going on and since I've gotten
out I was still in the halfway house
when I talked to Damien so I talked to
Damien I tell Damien look men I asked
him you know to look at the story and
helped me with the summary yeah let's
write a backstory what's your opinion
what do you think
Donovan's ready to talk he's ready to
tell everybody I didn't do it Damien
spins me oh I read the story a long time
ago when it was on the website I'll let
you know let me let me let me read it
again this weekend I call him after the
weekend what happened is you read I
didn't get time I'll read it in a couple
days call him again a couple days later
oh I started to read it I'm gonna read
it this weekend I didn't do it then
eventually he just doesn't answer the
phone or return a text yeah
he didn't want to talk about it so I
tried to have a discussion with he just
won't even discuss pinning and spinning
and spinning Blaine on the other hand
Blaine's [ __ ] a maniac Blaine has an
assistant that sent me while I was in
the halfway house sent me a [ __ ]
email saying he had read the whole thing
and that it was just nothing but blatant
lies and I was like so I can't he said
and if I didn't remove it within the
next ten days he was filing a lawsuit so
I came back and I said well first of all
I'm not gonna be threatened I feel
pretty confident that I am protected by
the First Amendment and that even as
they felon you can't take that from
I said and you're some [ __ ] guy in
prison I said so listen I said I'm not
doing that but what I will do is this
plane I said anything in this document
that you show me that I cannot prove or
that I've said is 100% true and isn't I
will certainly redact it or I will I
will rewrite the entire thing
based on the evidence you can provide
right so he comes back and he says you
said this and you said that night any
new where did you get that information
and I said well I got that from the IRS
agent or the Secret Service agent that
no it was the FDA FDLE agent that
testified at your sentencing are they
satisfied during your trial the trial
that you lost are you saying that the
FDLE agent wide or FBI whoever it was I
think was FDLE are you saying he lied
cause you lost trial so clearly it was
believed so I feel pretty confident
about that one well where did you get
these numbers there's no proof that I
have any offshore accounts with any
money in and I go where do I get that
the offshore accounts well here's where
I got it and then I say this document
this this you told the IRS agents this
this this this this said and I have
proof that money was wired here here
here and I have proof that you win it I
so I explained the whole thing passes on
that then he comes back well what about
this you said this I said where'd I get
that I got that from your factual
stipulations which you stipulated to at
sentencing so I got that from what you
said or are you telling me that you lied
to the court because that's where I got
that from what you said what you've
written comes back well you said that
the FBI proved that I was funneling
money offshore debt you don't know what
you're talking about he was the FBI this
went on for a by the way a month back
forth back through his assistant yeah he
comes back and he says he says the FBI
wasn't even involved in my case or in
capital Bloo you don't know what you're
talking about and I come back and I go
Blayne I said you're absolutely right
but when I did a Freedom of Information
Act for a PFG and on Wilson Dorf coupled
with a request for any
information for with capital blue I got
the FBI documents which stated that you
were liquidating the assets you were
liquidating the company and you were
shipping all the money offshore and that
loosened or fur was working with you to
funnel money offshore and I gave him the
I gave him the actual numbers of the
documents and I said I suggest you do a
Freedom of Information Act for the
Chicago field office for the FBI you'll
get the same documents and I never heard
from that [ __ ] again
he told me was gonna sue me Sam no he
knows you got it covered
I got you bro I'm not [ __ ] around what
happened to loosen Dorf
oh no if he's still in prison how long
did he got like yeah like I think we had
a good run over 65 at least probably so
yeah poor bastard yeah poor bastard like
half a billion Isaac you almost feel
like you didn't do it in jail ever'one
your Ponzi scheme although you had a
good run your Ponzi thing falls apart
and then you figure [ __ ] it I'm going
out on top and you botched that [ __ ]
[Laughter]